sauf les deux voitures ont cuisiné
dauphinois c'est sa 2e dauphine la
cidrerie vous en voyez vous voilà des
potirons ben ali potiron qui a été cuit
tout simplement sur lui même c'est à
dire on l'a mis dans une casserole avec
une toute petite goutte d'eau de façon à
ce qu'ils ne brûlent pas et puis on la
cuit en un ami 750 g
il s'agit d'un soufflet pour quatre
personnes
mais naturellement ses 750 grammes ont
terriblement réduit parce que la plupart
à faire la plus grande quantité d'eau
s'est évaporé les coûts baissent alors
on pourrait le faisons attention qu'il y
avait fait cuire cinq sens inverse c'est
à dire au début ouvert bien si tu es
ensuite découvert alors voyez vous on va
passer cela au tamis et au travers d'un
tamis de métal mais vous n'avez ni aucun
assises annuelles
je n'ai mis qu'un tout petit peu de sel
alors une goutte d'eau et un peu de
cette affaire très attention c'est très
important parce que au fond leur cour je
le potiron le monde a cité la citrouille
c'est de l'eau tout de même alors c'est
il ya trop d'eau bref autant lever la
plus grande quantité possible violence
est un petit peu ligne eux aussi ce qui
fait que ça ne passe pas très très
facilement
tenez vous allez être gentil qu'a t elle
continuer à tapoter comme cela
facilement transporter un tout petit jeu
n'ont pourtant fait capoter si je vais
me faire des ennemis parmi les
ingénieurs du son se fait un champ par
terry n'ont actuellement la fera
davantage tout à l'heure
alors voyez vous pendant que vous faites
ce que vous allez faire continuer à
passer je prends une cuillerée par
personne de sauce béchamel que les trois
délits que ça mais ça ce n'est pas
obligée elle peut-être chose ça n'a rien
à voir les personnes 4 personnes 4
cuillère de sauce béchamel un peu
épaisses combien de temps il a fallu
faut qu'elle en soit là bas qu alors il
a fallu qu'une petite demi-heure alors
voyez vous je ramolli ici légèrement
cette sauce béchamel qui est très épais
ce jeu je le dis bien car je le précise
car c'est important étant donné que vous
allez voir tout à l'heure la purée
réjouit la purée de deux tirs ont fait
au contraire assez liquide alors ça y
est je crois que vous pouvez temps et
nous allons le faire violemment pour
faire tomber ce qui est de notre côté du
tamis voilà merci castriste vous
l'emportez oui voyez vous alors il ya
encore un peu d'eau c'est faux je vais
l'éliminer
le maximum voyez vous
j'élimine l'eau qui est dedans enfin
l'accord n'était pas très nourrissant
vous à les supplier puis je m'en avait m
le potiron avec ce qu'ils avaient rejeté
la du point rappelons que j'avais le dos
tourné un peu de sel un peu de poids
bien résister l'origine vas tu as la
voilà ça aussi c'est terminé merci mille
fois
alors nous allons mettre maintenant si
vous voulez me donner ces deux petits
bols bleu et jaune qui sont au bol en a
ici je n'avais pas d'un fouet car le
mélange se fera beaucoup mieux au fouet
mais ça vous aimez beaucoup serré du
tout et j'espère que c'est peut-être
existants
olala ça c'est la côte et liquides du
potiron est aux normes sociales que la
béchamel soit non c'est ce que j'ai dit
tout à l'heure catherine si vous aviez
némouthé j'ai dit qu'elle pouvait être
chaude fois ça n'a aucune importance
au contraire même serait plutôt un
avantage à être chaud oui messieurs j'ai
besoin que mon mac os manière mon
souffle et cuisent assez lentement
tout compte fait assez lentement vous
voilà oui alors ici j'ai terminé avec ce
fou et merci et je vais ajouter
comment alors ici quatre journées c'est
ta vie un jeune 9 pas faire ça 1 pour
une photo est équitable ainsi un jeune
bref une cuillère devait jamais c'est ça
les unités en un jour on en lien se fait
accompli c'est comme ça que nous faisons
la cuisine le 15e temps est
classiquement le temps de l'entente
seulement la 4 jaunes d'oeuf pour le
moment
et voilà quatrièmes bon et bien les
autres ont tout le monde en terminé
d'ailleurs toutes les transitions on va
s'en servir a pas encore été passée
voilà merci
alors les quatre jeunes noyés vous je
m'en vais les incorporer je la met tout
de suite dans un coin comme ceux-ci là
et puis je m'en vais lire incorporé à un
beau mélange parce que je veux que le
mélange soit bien fait et puis je vais
ajouter un peu de fromage de gruyère
râpé
il doit y en avoir besoin
non s'il faut marcher en fait je vais
ajouter une demie poignet par personne
c'est à dire de poignées pour 4 voilà
c'est suffisant viens là c'est
maintenant quatre et nous allons monter
les blancs d'oeuf
alors c'est ça le bruit quand vous avez
promis voilà à langer quelque part des
blancs 9 alors j'en ai quatre ici n'est
ce pas je veux ajouter 2 mais l'info en
réalité 6 1 et 2 voulant bien voudra
mais croyez-moi incroyable ici vous
allez faire ce truc eh bien je vois
qu'on veut pas faire grand chose quand
je fais le bruit épouvantable comme si
vous vous résignez au sol vous pliez vos
coussins tard non j'aurais essayé d'en
faire le moins possible
depuis cinq ans dix ans cette émission
se sert même pas eu un peu près les
mêmes plus en plus en plus gros salaires
enfin toujours présent alors on pourrait
parler un petit peu de gastronomie
dauphinois si on voulait commenter
bon eh bien je pense que le grand dragon
gastronomie de france c'est tout de même
le gratin dauphinois
évidemment le to play de potiron est
parti de ce folklore mais c'est surtout
le matin depuis moi si je vais partir le
gratin dauphinois pour représenter la
hadopi ne sait qu'en réalité c'était
l'émission qui aurait été trop court
trop courte et à la fois trop courte
pour la préparation des plombes pour la
cuisson on n'avait rien pu faire pour en
quelque sorte que mais c'est ainsi enfin
on peut en parler quand même ce gratin
dauphinois doit tester avec des pommes
de terre de montagnes si possible en
prêtant en au filet que celles des
villages reculés n'ont pas besoin de
peur tout est possible
le croire alors en fait dont on coupe
dont dépendent de terre les assises de
seine et le poids un peu de muscle car
on les a mis dans un plat que l'on a
préalablement passé avec de l'ail profit
rail comme on porte la la casserole pour
la fondue et on retrouve les pommes de
terre
deux frères de l'est le thème raconté
qu'elle et ont tué selon vous tout
doucement y ajoute en rogne en ajoutant
pas l'air il ya plusieurs écoles a su
qu'ils prônent à tony est ce qu'il faut
lire manger ce qui incombe à chaque
étape et discuter voilà bien voyez pas
été trop lents dans les médias
d'ailleurs un tout petit chalet qui vous
embaucher dans sa c4 privée alors
tourner tout doucement si vous voulez me
faire dire voilà parce que si on est
bien tout à la porte
oui mais voilà alors je vais cuir d'une
partie de souffler seulement parce que
parce que trop long comment vous faites
mentir non je veux en faire un métier
mais il n'attend pas aussi grand que la
préparation je viens de faire ceci
uniquement parce que je vous ai dit que
la gestion de cuisson d'un soufflé comme
ça serait d'environ 40 minutes alors les
enfants la moitié ça fera vingt minutes
de l'appareil non c'est fini à bruit
c'est fini fini fille voilà alors voyez
vous je note qu'il est bien sympathique
mélange bien qu'on dise à un très net
rapport avec le soufflé au fromage
si ce n'est qu'on a beaucoup de points
communs y aller comme il est jaune foncé
très français même et je dois dire que
déjà à l'odeur à wissant très fort un
bruit parce que se sentir très fort
c'est pas tellement cet appel que genre
à petit ami simon que vous doivent être
que la baptisait les prix un petit plus
c'est ce que je fais un plancher
non non voilà on va leur donner la
moitié
oui je n'aimais plus de monde se tient
jusque là non c'est bien comme ça vous à
voir il va il va souffler merci cadres
et non plus du tout eu
alors je vais aller la mettre au fond je
vais ouvrir le four d'abord et puis je
m'en vais le porter je surveillerai la
crise ont de temps en temps bien entendu
your comment may four moyen cette chimie
c'est à dire le maximum étant huit
foyers au gmi à cette maman je me suis
arrangée pour que le four ne soit pas
trop chaud au moment où je le mets il
vaut mieux que je pousse le four pendant
la cuisson
ces beaux arts vient maintenant de
remonter à quelque chose qui n'a pas
saisi 3 quelque chose qui est je croire
amusant et j'apporte peuvent s'adresser
de violence ici il suffit que le souffle
et karine bon nous allons diminuer de
cuisson par conséquent ça me va oui mais
ça se tire ça suffira vous verrez qu en
17 minutes allons le refaire ici une
petite soupe au potiron vous êtes du
monde s'est fait aider je sais pas
peut-être mais en fait je voudrais
quelques petites combinaisons
alors voici du potiron qui a été tué ce
n'est pas nécessaire et ce n'est pas
nécessaire du tout d'entrée du potiron
et tu fais on peut très bien
en plus ils produiront purement et
simplement cru il suffit à ce moment là
de mettre au moins d'eau n'est ce pas
oui parce que je leur ai pu me répéter
bien sûr mais le potiron 6 cellules en
haine de la foi alors mois ci voici le
potiron et de l'eau nous allons à ces
zones est simplement un génie c'est bien
une casserole à chauffer parce que nous
sommes ou d'enseigner une petite
combinaison qui me semblent amusante
merci catherine line deneault carrie là
en baisse elles n'ont pas le poids
quelle poisse et on aura ya un côté vous
êtes vraiment l'impression et vosges et
me dury simplement à blanchir c'est à
dire les met dans l'eau froide
il est tard il n'a pas encore oui mais
alors ils allaient bruire je m'en vais
simplement mais finit bien
je garde le voulait à poivre la ram 1
parce que vraiment vous n'êtes pas
gentil
là je me sens et je mène ce rire qui est
simplement blanchi que le veston le coq
iront à la seconde qualité que l'on
pouvait voir oui et je m'en vais
mélanger cela comme il était déjà blanc
un grand geste européen
c'était important à dire qu'il est
mouillé résultats au nom donc on ne
réduira pas alors ici un peu plus de
chair
ces chaleurs et puis nous allons réparer
alors c'est là où arrive ma petite
astuce qui attribue ce lien vous non le
nom alors du beurre que voici
et puis si vous voulez approcher les
petits légumes qui sont lents voilà
alors pognon du fenouil
c'est très important parce que c'est
amusant de changer un petit peu les
bouderies carottes oignons et fenouil
c'est par le feu n'est pas absolument
pas obligatoire mais du céleri par
exemple est très bon là un peu soutenue
dans la casserole
la réunion c'est pas la fête ses dix ans
portage et puis là nous n'allons pas
immédiatement mettre les légumes dedans
par conséquent il n'y a pas trop de
chaleur et aux 1 le germe était pas très
joli l'envié un oignon se suffire à
l'idée de vous et du sirti bien que
jeunesse se passe là oignons et puis
j'aime avait également ajouté un peu de
tout ça je vais couper en petits
morceaux aussi
voilà ça suffit roi et même tenir dans
la bonne voie
si on veut nous a gâtés m'a protégé bien
j'ai pas mon titre et carottes
car voilà fenouil ou céleri fenouil
galerie et oignons
je vais leur donner un tout petit coup
d'oeil à mon souffle et aux faux qu'ils
pensaient voilà
qu'est ce qu'il dit et fait il va bien
ça va tout doucement je m'en occuperai
bien entendu alors ici nous allons en
faisant revenir ses légumes légèrement
on leur fait pas en nos couleurs ça va
venir
alors là ça vous nous mettez là le feu
tirant à bout c'est gros c'est parfait
aleo savent accueillir dans les dix
minutes qui mauvaise ou les quinze
minutes qui nous restera que les jeunes
12 12 minutes ça sera cuite
parce que s'il avait fallu quinze
minutes c'était la même chose il faut
que ça qui dans le temps qui nous reste
c'est ça ça sera cuit alors elle était
bon alors ici voilà mon petit trou n'est
ce pas il consiste à prendre un petit
linge plus petit que tu reviens ce site
via une vieille détritus arrière une
petite reprise il y en a même plusieurs
et on peut prendre une petite et amine
en général ça soit avec l'as vécu avec
une petite et amis alors l'espoir nos
couleurs comme vous allez voir et je
pourrais peut-être montré en quatre et
vous montrer comment on peut faire pour
s'amuser avec un potiron et vous faire
un musée avait encore mais ça peut venir
bref où il a rejoint le passé par là
alors oui si la halo et bien on va vous
faire avoir
on va dans l'hérault bien avant la crise
de nerfs de couler je vais regarder
aussi au four encore une fois très bien
vous équipe
pour le moment ça va être bon alors ici
allez-vous nous allons couper comme
ceux-ci l'intérieur du potiron voulait
me donner en pl quelconque ont dégagé
graine n'importe quoi en bloc tous cas
depuis que donc très quelconque en même
temps là ça on veut vraiment rien à
faire
ou bien ce sont 900 les grès 6 a certes
pas de médicine al voulez savoir ce à
quatre et tenir ses très bons à manger
comme sa grille et lier les graines de
potiron
je vous préviens c'est cet excellent
mois devait aller récupérer ces beaux
messieurs
j'aime pas je vais j'ai encore quelque
chose à faire merci complétée met
davantage
c'est vraiment tout cela alors je vais
terminer la petite astuce ne vous parler
maintenant c'est prêt anvers
tout ça dans les timides gère dix
reprises
et puis on pas un petit bourg ce morceau
de fil comme ceux ci c'est pas difficile
du film je suis tu arriverais jamais là
voyez où comme ceci et puis on attache
ça va nous amener vous allez voir
pourquoi regarder le foot non savoir
donc j'ai confiance je t'aime papa
chance d'avoir confiance lors un couteau
voilà et puis ceux ci ainsi que la grèce
qui est patient avait le croire
comment renverser tout ça et nous allons
mettre ça au milieu de la soupe au
potiron que voilà on attache à lens du
panier si bien qu'au bar où tu ne vaux
pas faire sauter bien entendu il va
retrouver le goût des petits chalets le
petit enzo mien ne trouvais ça sous la
tente
voilà alors ceci est terminée alors
catherine je voudrais que pendant les
quelques minutes qui nous restent vous
nous fassiez voir quelque chose oui ça
sera à vous de travailler un petit peu
j'aurais compassion petit décor ne
demandez pas de couper samedi décor avec
des légumes que voilà si je nie dans un
potiron pendant que moi ne nous
arrangeait le couvercle de se produire
on vous allez manger les fruits ledent
après vous pourrez faire exactement tout
ce qu'on voudrait c'est plus du goût
dans l'asymétrie figure qu'à vous à
votre cas là vous avez quelques
avantages
vous avez besoin d'être défendus que
j'ai est ce qu'on met au fond pour que
ce soit ce livre rouge pas vous pourriez
mettre des poissons la salade pas cela
qui est tout à fait rien ça là je les
habille et de salage des artichauts et
alors on amène sao mais ça en vie un
jour où on fait un potiron comme ça a
soufflé le potiron
on peut présenter on peut présenter
quel est grosso celui-là ne suis pas
pouvoir le mettre le décor de tarn et
n'en voulez me faire dire où j'apparais
vous arranger mari c'était très joli
dans le panier
je mettais un artichaut deux mois et
bien moi je suis encore le débarrasser
ici tous ceux qui n'ont même pas
tellement sale et 9 est la suivante au
potiron
je veux mettre en place face à ce
conflit sur le manipuler par la suite du
maïs est merveilleux ne sonne pas à quel
moment remettait ça sur la table
vraiment un
comment arrive je m'occupe de mots ses
citoyens contre elle après tu reviens
ici aussi le mauvais possible
non non je ne voulais pas qu'il soit
trop cuit pas assez alors je le
surveille attentivement ce que vous
n'avez pas répondu à ma question qu'en y
avait une question est oui
ce que vous mettez ça
moi je sais pas je voudrais que vous
met-il mix couvercle dessus alors pour
blessure que vous laissiez quand même
non et alors que certains mets ça sur le
tard à temps mais oui alors vous allez
le maître ici je trouve que c'était
beaucoup plus général d'un panier
c'était très bien arrangé voilà moi je
me dis qu'il se passe quelque chose là
non non c'est pas ça le jour je vais
regarder au four encore une fois ça va
très très bien
je suis ravi de ce qui se passe dans le
coup alors ça y est vous trouvez que
c'est bien ou c'est bien moi aussi je
crois que c'était très joli petit
vraiment je pense qu'il faudrait
peut-être que ça a eu un petit air
penché comme si c'était déjà révolu
voyez comme ça non oui ça fait un très
joli décor de table il n'y a pas que les
fleurs qui peuvent faire des décors de
tap
croyez-moi on peut faire de très jolis
décors également avec des allophones du
coup leur nom s'est défendue non je n'en
parle pas d'ailleurs il ses artichauts
vers l'allemand il ya un moyen de dire
aux gens ton est ennuyé avec ça oui
parce que je ferais remarquer que ça
tiendra jusqu'à un petit couteau dont
vous allez voir alors je n'ai pas je
n'ai pas ici
pardon merci cadets je n'ai pas de dunes
une aiguille une aiguille une baguette
jaguar était alors les eaux
on peut très bien le fixer comme ça avec
une aiguille quelque chose qui alors là
ça tient à pas de question au congrès
c'est pas très joli avec un couteau cvo
vilain mais ce n'est pas embêtant alors
ici ça compte
le maçon
[Musique]
sango santé sainte catherine alors voyez
vous maintenant la deuxième partie de
l'opération
nous allons ajouter du lait bio on
ajoute ici environ un demi litre de lait
non c'est plus tard
et puis en quelques secondes nous
enlèverons le petit paquet des légumes
c'est nous versons le potage alors la
folie dauphiné précisément j'en ai
beaucoup mangé dans mon enfance ça mais
je reconnais qu'il n'y avait pas le
petit piqué centrale on y mettrait
certainement pas d'oignons de carottes
et de fenouil
comme vous l'avez fait ce qu'il doit
être extrêmement bons et doit donner
beaucoup de alors je crois que terminer
nous allons pouvoir présenter le soufflé
tout de suite et si oui c'est sûr mais
avant ça avant cela je vais me présenter
le frottage alors je voudrais le verset
le potage va être cuit peut-être autres
minutes plus tard on le regarde et
d'ailleurs très sincèrement vous et moi
que l'on regarde et nous irons jusqu'à
le goût de taissy de la cuisson du riz
puisque c'est le riz qui va nous nous
volent nos idées
alors voulez-vous voir tenez je vais
vous en donner en grains en grains de
riz pour aller rouler roulent pas eh
bien voyez c'est donc puis je vais
enlever le petit bouquet que c'est très
facile à ferrié vous avec la petit bout
de fil qui est là vous rendez vous avez
mis didier couteaud coûteux la critique
vers votre nez sur le fait que vous
n'ayez pas un étalage de couteau j'en
avais un tout à l'heure mais je vais
enlever pour aider à se débarrasser
alors voilà la soupe au potiron et nous
étudions très épaisse très très très
épaisse alors on peut y ajouter
naturellement pour l'éclaircir un peu
rien après ça on n'a absolument plus fin
voyez où on peut l'éclaircir avec du
lait toujours au exactement surtout un
peu de crème c'est encore meilleur
voilà doit être très épaisse un jeu je
peux j'insiste mais vraiment voyez-vous
la cuillère doit tenir dedans elle tient
on sait ça s'est fini c'est fini je vais
maintenant le souffle et que l'on
servira quand même
après car il faut quand même plus où
trouver une place à sa souplesse
il ya beaucoup de fumée là mais ce n'est
pas grave c'est simplement un morceau de
papier voyez vous que j'ai mis dans
votre papier non mais c'est très
important explique sachs j'explique
qu'il faut mettre quelques fois un
morceau de papier comme ça sur le
soufflet pour éviter que la chaleur du
four trop brutale lenoir 6 alors je vais
retirer ce morceau de papier tout simple
et puis je me retirais le souffle et lui
aussi
oui alors voila voila le soufflé nous
allons d'ailleurs si vous voulez bien
vous allez le goûter puisque vous êtes
parti aujourd'hui vous avez juré de me
faire brûler parce que ça alors je suis
sûr que attendait bougez pas on va
prendre pour tirer leurs propres alors
d'aller couper le souffle et côté caméra
voilà avec une petite seconde d'émotion
pas la moins - je pense que vous devriez
goûter voilà voilà quatre ans alors
soyez gentils de goûter de me dire si ça
vraiment le goût de sortir et surtout
qu'on ne me vois pas dans ces conditions
là où elle voulait pas soufflé un tout
petit peu voilà je viens 4 et nous avons
donc réalisé un soufflé au potiron le
souffle court
seconde tournée vous une semaine il est
très bon très bon vous pouvez revenir et
puis aussi un petit décor au potiron
vraiment c'était le décor vous n'êtes
pas obligé de le manger mais ce soir
c'est peut-être ce que vous pouvez
préparer en allant très vite acheter un
gros potiron
[Musique]